I'm Tom mochi No thank you Chris first
of all I'm going to talk a bit about how
we do JavaScript application development
at Facebook we're going to do something
a little different jordan is actually
also going to present he's going to do
some of the technical stuff I'm going to
talk about the fluffy [ __ ] I'll get it
out of the way quick first of all we
asked ourselves this question many many
times how should we structure JavaScript
applications and more specifically
JavaScript applications that run in a
web browser
we're using node and doing all that fun
stuff too but I'm more interested in the
user interface side of things so that's
what we're going to talk about today
there are a lot of JavaScript frameworks
that aim to answer this question
these frameworks have allowed us to move
the web forward as a real application
platform
if Peter Higgins is the room I want to
call out that dojos up here because dojo
did it first as he would say or dojo
already did that but the consensus is
basically that an MVC style architecture
is best and it's not just MVC right it's
mvvm or as angular calls it Model View
whatever I really like that one I
actually really like angular in the the
declarative data binding I think that's
kind of the holy grail in terms of api's
all of these architectures and
frameworks have one thing in common
though and that's models
so typically models in these frameworks
implement observable objects with an
events API developers use bi-directional
data binding to bind their views to
their models as your models change or
views can be updated and as your views
change they can update the models which
then propagates out to other views
excuse me
so this observable model pattern
encourages mutation though and mutation
is complex so a few years ago starting
with our chat rewrite we tried to start
structuring our application a little bit
differently we wanted to minimize the
amount of mutation that developers had
to deal with mutation is a necessary
evil you have to deal with it but we
want to minimize the amount of mutation
that developers have to code themselves
let me show you what I mean by that
here's the structure for a simple
application in this diagram you'll
notice that all updates go through a
single flow so all updates including
user input they go through a single
channel
this is one directional data binding
those updates eventually reach the views
in the simplest way that we have found
conceptually to structure and render our
views is to just try and avoid mutation
altogether so what I mean by that is
anytime any of your data changes just
blow away your view completely and
rerender it from scratch now I know what
you're thinking that's not going to work
right the Dom can be slow you know
browsers are going to be it's going to
be prohibitively expensive to try and do
this to try and just reenter HTML
everything every time anything changes
especially in a real-time app or
something that's really interactive so
you know conceptually this is what we're
going for though this is what we want we
want to build something that gives us
the conceptual simplicity of re
rendering from scratch on every single
event um but you know without the
overhead because that's primitively
expensive so about 18 months to 2 years
ago and missing the exact date we
started working on a javascript library
that helps us do that and we call it
react so that was all the fluffy stuff
and I'm going to let Jordan come up and
talk about some of the more technical
details of this all right so like tom
was saying one of the things that we
strive for when we were building our
component framework is that we want to
minimize the amount of developer facing
mutations that the developers exposed to
and so react takes a different approach
in a few ways the first is that it's
highly declarative and so that doesn't
that means that not just your initial
rendering but also a lot of your updates
are implemented via some kind of a
declaration that's a non mutated
description of what your UI should be ok
so we don't have observable data binding
inside of react we don't ship with it I
imagine you could actually use it with
react but a lot of the things that you
might reach to observe observable data
binding for in order to implement react
provides a different way to do that and
declaration is the way that we do that
so along with react we are shipping an
embeddable XML syntax and we're calling
that JSX so this is similar to a lot of
the work and language proposals that
might have happened in the past but
we're unique
a few ways and I'll let you take a look
at what that looks like first okay so
here we have react used with JSX and so
we are creating a message variable and
we're assigning it to a react div
instance and it has an invested interest
is
are not exactly what you're used to
they're not Dom nodes so there's special
reactives and I'll get to why that's
important at the bottom there we render
it so one thing that makes JSX unique is
that it's a very lightweight transform
all we do is transform these tags into
function invocations so it's not quite
as nice looking but you can see it even
preserves the line the line number so if
you pass this to your linter it'll catch
like tags that are out of scope your
link messages will appear in the right
line and everything's low tooling is the
key here
but JSX is also optional if you want to
build with react so if you like this you
can write that but I think you guys
would agree that this is a lot better so
react is more than just about Dom nodes
and Dom components but react is
primarily a way for you to abstract
reusable code and high to implementation
details of your application UI so the
primary focus of react is allowing you
to build custom components so the way
that you use a custom component is a lot
like the way that you would use a div or
a span we can use the XML syntax JSX to
instantiate it so we have XML attributes
text and a non-action callback provided
here and these become the properties of
your view instance or of your react
component instance so you probably want
to check out how we implement or define
this action button a couple things just
to note is that we make one call to
react up create class and then we also
supply a render function so what this
does this creates a class to model your
component and it will extend or it will
mix in all the base functionality of the
react of the react base so react is not
an object oriented for
Geist framework though we use a little
bit of inheritance just because that
lends itself naturally to what
JavaScript is good at but other than
that the core paradigm here is an
object-oriented so I thought I would
call that out so you can supply other
methods here and they get mixed into
your prototype and so the moment you
define the action button you can
actually reference it it becomes in
scope and your linter won't complain if
action button wasn't in scope you know
your linter would say you know this is
not defined so it's a very JavaScript
centric language this JSX and so render
has one purpose and that is just is to
describe your view at any point in time
so that doesn't mean just the initial
render but at any point in time so let's
go through what that might look like
over a series of updates ok so we're
starting out with a shell here we have
an outer button and an inner span so we
want to do something interesting with
the properties that were given we want
to be able to interpret them into a user
experience so what we do is we take the
property text and route it down into the
inner span and the way you do that is
you can refer to these XML attributes
that are passed in via this dot props so
you can see they're in the center where
we're routing the book flight text into
the inner span but these XML attributes
don't just have to be strings because
we're in JavaScript and JSX and wrap is
JavaScript focused so we have a function
that we're being supplied here in the on
action callback and we're routing that
to the buttons on click so in action
buttons on action is a Dom buttons on
click in this case and so it helps to
view at least initially react component
as a transform from these properties
into a user experience and you can just
kind of imagine these being routed to
their proper locations but react is more
than just a routing tool you can do any
kind of transform that you or you can do
any JavaScript expression that you want
inside of these interpolation braces so
that means that we can uppercase the
text and so anytime the text changes
this will always be uppercase so like I
mentioned earlier render isn't just your
initial isn't just your initial
rendering but it's actually your
rendering over
points in time so as your properties
change as your properties change the
render output change changes and then
react satisfies your render function
it'll make sure that the user
experiences render exactly as you've
described at any point in time and so
what react will do is it will find the
minimal set of Dom mutations needed to
make that happen
so let's say that you're you're let's
say that your texts have changed so
react will find that the only thing that
needs to change is that inner innermost
spans text content so I'll explain a
little bit more about how that works
but but the key here is that you can
react these previously abstracted
components we already saw the action
button and that was a simple and
stateless component but you know you'll
eventually want to build something more
complex something more like an
application it will have its own
internal state so let's do that so this
is a simplest stateful component that
you could imagine it's the counter has
an increment and decrement button and
you'll see that we're actually reusing
our action button that we created in the
last example so we have two action
buttons one that increments one that
decrements so this is new if you want to
build an application and you don't just
want simple stateless views you want to
be able to define some kind of a state
machine you want your component to be
able to assume the role of a state
machine in some way and so state
machines need an initial State so good
initial state is a special function that
react allows you to implement in order
for you to define what your initial
state is so in this case we're setting
the count member of our state to be
equal to the initial count property that
was passed in and the example there
passes for so we're going to initialize
our state to be 4
so this is where it gets really
interesting the same way that we could
refer to props in our render function
and assume that they're always up to
date because react ensures that we can
also refer to state inside of our render
function and assume that they're always
up to date so anytime your properties or
your state changes render will render
will remain satisfied by the react
system so the the content of that h 3
there will always show the states count
and you can put any expression there
again you can put a ternary that decides
what to render their special messaging
depending on like certain counts okay so
to make these state changes actually
happen we bind the add to count method
to our action buttons on action and so
when we increment one we're going to add
to count passing in 1 because we bound
it there in the callback and so what we
do is we set state which is like a state
transition if our components are state
machine then set state is how you
perform state transitions on the state
machine what we do is we set the next
count to be equal to the current count
plus the Delta alright so how does this
work so there's two main passes here or
there's two main stages to the react
component life lifecycle there's the
initial rendering and so what we do for
the sake of flexibility is we compute a
giant markup string and so react will
traverse your entire component hierarchy
tree and we'll create a markup string
that injects into wherever you render it
now there's a second phase to that
initial to that initial stage there and
that is that we instantiate all the
backing objects and attach all the event
handlers what's interesting here is that
these two things can occur in two
different places on your system two
different computers
anywhere in the world so you could you
could in theory render the markup on a
server and then attach all the event
handlers and instantiate all the backing
views on the client to completely
separate machines we could talk a lot
more about that too
but the second primary phase of a
components lifecycle is when these
changes in data happen so we need to
make the UI fresh and that's what
reconciliation is is this updating new
year it's making sure that your UI is
updated anytime any of your data sources
change and so how this works is that it
recursively compares subsequent
invocations of render and it takes the
outputs of those and it creates a the
smallest if possible to make sure that
your UI is is up to date
so if only one little Dom node changes
or if only one class name or one style
attribute on on a Dom node that's
possibly 50 levels deep in your view
hierarchy changes will will serialize
these diff commands basically over this
logical bridge to this other part of the
system that will apply to that smallest
mutation and so again just to illustrate
that in more depth here if this text
changes from book flight to book hotel
only that span the only dom command that
will ever execute is to make sure that
that spans inter text has changed we
won't even read from the dom actually
okay so anybody that's giving a
presentation at a conference is going to
show you the most contrived examples and
so react is no different but there's
also an escape hatch or several escape
hatches that you can that you can tap
into in the react system so some of the
things you're going to want to do is
you're going to want to integrate with
your existing frameworks or your
existing code and so we allow plenty of
ways to let you to let you do that and
and another more interesting escape
hatch that we have is a way for you to
be able to help guide this process along
so react is finding this diff the
smallest possible set of Don changes
that need to be applied and that can
take some time so what we allow is we
allow you to prune out a lot of the
search space and help react and help
guide react along to find these small as
to come these smallest ifs and so those
are completely optional you can you can
put them in your code or you can take
them out and the same application runs
just faster or slower
so it's tree it's a it's treating this
optimization step as a complete a
completely separate part of development
it's not core you don't start with the
optimizations but you you identify the
bottlenecks and apply them where
necessary
okay so I'm going to kick it back to
Tomo and he's going to tell a little bit
about the history of react in the future
thanks Jordan yeah so the interesting
thing about that escape hatch is that's
actually pretty important to being able
to iterate on your product over time so
another hook that you get is basically
at any point you can say just give me a
Dom node and let me write JavaScript so
one of the examples that we had up here
was and we just trimmed it for content
but like you can basically say okay I
have this other plugin from some other
framework that does like Auto growing
text areas or that does like an
autocomplete ER and you can basically
wire those things up via that escape
hatch really easily and this is actually
why this framework was able to be
successful at Facebook we didn't have to
convert everything we could use it kind
of piecemeal but yeah I mean this
started a long time ago this started
probably eighteen months ago
somewhere between 18 months and two
years ago and you know at this point
we're using this all over Facebook calm
if you've ever commented on anything on
Facebook or liked anything if you've
ever talked and chat or integrated or
used your buddy list and or even use
your notifications there's a bunch of
different places where we've been using
this for a really long time
and it's been working out really really
well for us so about a year ago when
Instagram joined Facebook we had this
this is the first time that this ever
happened to us we had somebody else who
wasn't on Facebook's infrastructure that
wanted to use Facebook's infrastructure
and you know we've presented a bunch of
stuff at J's conf in the past and you
know historically our you know excuses
kind of been you know it's pretty tough
to divorce things from our
infrastructure but Instagram joined us
and they really wanted to use this and
they sort of acted like a forcing
function for us Rebecca made a great
comment about writing your code as if
it's open-source so what we started to
do is we just went through all of react
and all of the build steps and all of
those tool and all the tooling behind it
and we built it or you know refactored
it and rebuilt it such that it was able
to be open sourced so that Instagram
could use it on Instagram calm in fact
Instagram calm was their first project
that they wanted to take on after they
joined Facebook and in a matter of a
week or two they built all of Instagram
comm profiles on this system which was
amazing for us we were really excited
about that
they basically again they
as a forcing function for us to kind of
get our house in order and you know this
you know divorce are our infrastructure
from this library and some other
libraries so you know all of Instagram
comm is unreacted ow
and you know it gave us practice with
somewhat of an external client so the
logical next step for all the people
that have been working on this is you
know you know we want to open-source
this and actually incidentally we did
that about a half-hour ago
so ha if you check out Facebook thank
you so again you know I want to be
really humble here this is just
something that we're using it's
something that works really well for us
we're really interested to get any
feedback we can you know definitely
check out the link you know we're really
open to feedback there's a Google Group
there's an IRC chat room there's you
know all sorts of like on github there's
a you know issues and stuff there so you
know that's react and you know thank you
you